[Music]
all right let's go to k in tampa florida
what's up k
um i'm
well
happy belated anniversary thank you
thank you thank you for taking my call
of course of course of course uh how are
we doing
i'm doing okay today um
i've been having good days and bad days
but
um today's an okay day talk to me about
it what's going on
well
i'm really looking for advice on
how i can
my husband and i can best help our son
he is 18 years old so a legal adult
but he's
[Music]
recently been convicted
of a federal crime
and
is facing
prison time
he has not been sentenced yet
so we don't know exactly what it's going
to be
it's dealing with online
child pornography
and
so the attorney
has told us
basically with
this charge
to expect that he would
be sentenced to a minimum of
five years in jail
and obviously then thereafter
um have a lifetime felony conviction and
have to register as a sex offender
all because
of
uh
something stupid um
which
i told them
i told all my boys when they turned 18 i
can no longer protect you from stupid
yeah
well and and i know you know this
um
but
one of the things i think holds back
parents and moments like this
is
um
you really get forced into
picking a side
and i want you
and your husband as y'all move forward
and we haven't even got to your question
yet but i want you all to move forward i
want you to
work to hold all of this
okay
and what i mean by that is this
there is no innocent player in child
pornography
i i understand that i i know but
i'm not picking at you i just want you
to hold the whole thing okay so i'm not
talking down or anything like that you
just a picture of you and me sitting at
a bar okay or we're sitting grabbing
nachos together
it's i love my son
and i don't want him in jail
and what happened
he can't be around other people and
right so it's all of these things all
and there's kids that were hurt on the
other end of this so it's all that
wrapped up into one big messy
and that's the path forward when we're
grieving this kind of stuff which just
stinks um
let but i cut you off tell me about um
tell me how i can help i'm so sorry
about going through this what an
absolute mess across the board
yeah um i mean there's obviously not
much i can do
legally um
let me let me ask you this this is a
hard question
can i put you on the spot what would you
do
what would i do
yeah um because it's that it's a balance
between i don't want my kid in jail
i don't want my kid going to prison
and i don't want my kid
trafficking child pornography or holding
child like
hurting children like so what would you
do if you could
um
i guess
you know i
i'd look for alternatives to jail time
whether that's
no access to
anything online i'm fine with that yeah
um
you know
he's he's seeing a therapist regularly
now if
you know and
he'd be willing to do that you know for
the rest of his life to
have someone to hold him accountable and
that kind of thing but um
you know he he is on the
autism spectrum
he is socially immature
um
and i
think um
he was just
he it was it was his first year at
college he was looking to
meet some people and
ended up in an online chat room and
ended up texting with somebody and a
person
sent them some stuff and
um
you know when that that person was
arrested then they looked at his phone
and
because my son had been in receipt of
what that other person had sent him they
came after my son as well um i don't
think he was
looking for
that he was looking for
i don't know
here but here we find here we find
ourselves
um
how can i help you i'm just i'm
heartbroken by this whole mess i'm just
yeah
and i mean i i totally get that there's
a victim in this um
and um you know sometimes i feel like my
son's a victim um but i know that
there's
you know
every child that's involved in this
they're the victim too
i get that
um
i'm looking for advice on how to
best support my son
through the sentencing phase through the
incarceration phase
um
and hopefully if i'm still alive when it
gets
released from prison that um
i can help them beyond and
you know i
i just i don't know how to help him yeah
um other than just tell him hey
we love you
um
we'll always love you
and other than that i don't know what to
do i don't know how to help him
look forward
versus thinking this is
i'm afraid he's gonna say this is
the end of my life
and i might as well be dead and i'm
afraid he's gonna do something to hurt
himself has he threatened suicide before
um
when he was arrested okay he apparently
made some comments so they had some
concerns sure
so um
moving forward here's a couple things to
keep in mind okay
um the first thing is this
the sooner
you and your husband transition in your
hearts
from
we can stop this
we're beyond that this is where this is
we're going to make peace with what what
what's moving forward now
and we're not going to make people we
don't have to like it we don't we can
there can be days you wake up and think
i can't believe we're treating my 18
year old baby like this whatever the
thing is
the sooner you make peace with this
train is leaving the station
then you can be about what comes next
but as long as you're trying to drag
that train back into the station it's
going to take off and what it's going to
do is just drag you and your husband
behind you a lot of couples split up
over things like this because we one of
them didn't grieve it one of them
grieved too much the other one thought
and
it's sitting down and saying this is
happening our son um was involved
whether we think he was as involved five
years in jail worth it
he was involved in the worst of the
worst of the worst
and
thank god he got caught early
and
in five years he will
um what would be 23
he's he'll be still be a young young
young child you know that and then he'll
be out and then we're gonna figure out
what comes next there the word i want
you to keep in your mind is connection
and i don't know what that looks like
for you and your son
that might be a weekly
book study that you all do together for
the next five years
that might be you'll learn something
together like all learn spanish if you
learn spanish or whatever that thing is
but he's got to know that he's got two
people that are walking alongside him
even if they're not physically there
that makes sense
yeah
and so we're going to not double down on
what a victim i can't believe this like
nope you broke the law and when this
person texted either you asked for it or
you said sure i'd love to see it or you
didn't go to the authorities when it got
sent to you either way
here we are here we are
and
for a five-year sentence that that tells
me something else is going on either he
asked for it or participated in it or
there was some back and forth exchanges
something more than a single text
message one way for five years
so something else is involved but that's
a that's a whole other call here all
that to say is here's where it is we're
gonna do these five years with dignity
and we're gonna learn
and we're gonna keep our head up and
we're going to
see what does 23 gonna how is 23 going
to be different than 18 and that's the
goal that we're shooting for here
and we're going to have good behavior
and we're going to honor
the young children in our communities
and you and dad are gonna have to grieve
this like crazy because y'all had plans
and you'll have pictures in your head
and you'd already thought about what
graduation would look like
from college and i mean you have those
pictures in your head and you're gonna
have to spend some time grieving them
you don't want to have this conversation
at the supermarket hey how's your son
doing
uh they're at church or it's somebody
else's birthday party you don't have
these conversations and here we are
right
there's gonna have to be a dropping your
shoulders and sitting in this for a
minute
and by a minute i mean a season several
months it's gonna hurt and you'll have
to let that process happen
okay
it if you don't
it ends up in inflammatory responses it
ends up in rage it ends up in anger it
ends up in blame it ends up in a broken
marriage it ends up in a mess
okay
okay the single greatest book i've ever
read on grief in my opinion
is called finding meaning by david
kessler
i'd recommend you and your um husband
read that book together
and a chunk of that book is about david
kessler's work with parents who've lost
young children they've passed away
in many ways this is a loss for a season
okay
and grieving it in a similar fashion i
think would be really really helpful
okay and then connection connection
connection as hard as that's gonna be
and it's gonna be real hard
yeah okay
um
it may also be worth your soul um the
back end of grief is finding meaning
what are we gonna do in light of
it may be worth
it may be worth down the road
you and your husband finding ways to
volunteer support care for love
trafficked children
children who are sexually abused
children who are going through
deep challenges
as not so much a restitution but a
restoration
how can we be a part of the healing in
our community
that our son helped participate in some
of the hurt
it's similar when a
mother of a son
kills a young family in a drunk driving
accident and he passes away too
mom may get really involved in
alcohol regulations and drinking and
driving and uh she's gonna be about
dad's gonna be about healing the
community from something their kid was a
part of and that may be a conversation
you and your husband have together
what light can we shine in our community
in light of what our sun has done
so we can model here's what this looks
like
here's what service and finding meaning
looks like that's going to be down the
road a bit right now you just need a
season of grief
you season of hand-holding you can't get
in front of him and defend him this time
you know that
you can you can hold his hand
and say you gotta go you gotta go pay
the piper on this one
but mom still loves you and dad still
loves you and we're going to be here
with you every step of the way we're
going to be here when you get out
i'm so sorry k it's heartbreaking all
around is a big mess for everybody and
i'm so sorry you're going through this